le québec pourrait profiter de cet
investissement fournissions différentes
parties de batteries qui seront ensuite
assemblés dans cette usine ce qui est
clair c'est que la demande de véhicules
électriques est de plus en plus grande
on est passé de 580000 ventes de
véhicules électriques rechargeables dans
le monde c'était en 2015 à plus de 6
millions 700 mille en 2021 et le prix de
ses véhicules baisse de plus en plus
parce qu'il en coûte de moins en moins
cher de produire des batteries le coût
de production d'une batterie lithium-ion
est passé de 917 dollars américains le
kilowattheure à 137 dollars en 2020 avec
une prévision à 58 dollars en 2030 on va
en parler ce soir avec karim zaghib
professeur à l'université de concordia
et à l'université mais gaël également
spécialiste justement des batteries
lithium-ion bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous qu'est ce que ça
signifie cette annonce 5 milliards en
ontario aujourd'hui je pense est une
excellente nouvelle parce que la
majorité dit guy gras factory ils sont
aux etats-unis en europe bien sûr en
asie c'est pour la première fois au quai
au canada je pensais des bons nouvelle
non seulement pour le puits pour le
canada pour l'ontario et pour le québec
mais est ce que pour le québec parce que
le québec est complémentaire à l'ontario
où les deux provinces sont dans une
sorte de compétition pour être la vraie
filière des batteries au pensionnat une
grande complémentarité passe dans une
batterie dont on à l'anode la cathode
les folies ton et les composantes on a
besoin de ses composantes par exemple
dans la note en a besoin du cuir du
graphite on a le grès le graphite ici au
québec nouveau montré grafite on
additionne les tueurs de nîmes à ce cas
on a besoin du nickel du cobra du
phosphate et de l'aluminium et tous ces
matériaux ils sont là au québec donc et
l'écosystème québécois est très fort
donc ça va générer les composantes pour
lysine donc on a une cellule si on n'a
pas les anodes les catholiques ne peut
pas fabriquer une batterie mais est ce
qu'il ya une vraie volonté de
complémentarité seul entre les deux
provinces je pense que oui il ya une
vraie complémentarité pourquoi parce que
le québec il est spécifique en
particulier pour les camions les autobus
les motoneiges en a vu et aussi la
position de l'ontario c'est l'automobile
c'est la voiture et les ayons
complémentarité dans quelle industrie
des camions qui sont ici et là-bas tri
des matériaux ça sert pour les deux donc
moi j'ai vu toujours une complémentarité
entre les deux provinces l'ontario et le
québec sadi à une concurrence féroce on
voit le protectionnisme américain il ya
d'autres concurrents dans le mondial et
chinois bien sûr qu'ils sont là dans ce
marché là la place du québec la place de
l'ontario la place du canada dans le
marché de la batterie électrique cc
laquelle nous devrions travailler
ensemble par exemple la chine les
provinces en chine ils travaillent
ensemble la corée le japon donc
normalement il devrait avoir une
collaboration vraiment accrue entre les
provinces et en particulier aussi la
position du québec parce que la
fabrication des matériaux de l'anneau de
la cathode se fait avec
l'hydroélectricité
donc c'est des matériaux verts donc on
peut faire la traçabilité donc on peut
se positionner de que le canada peut
produire des cellules vert avec des
composantes qui vient décidant qu'il ya
aussi une chaîne de valeur qu'elle peut
se créer ici elle devient indépendant de
l'asie parce qu'aujourd'hui la majorité
des matériaux veut pas se cacher ça
vient en partie de la chine et d'autres
et ses matériaux cie voyage de
l'indonésie de la chine du chili de
l'afrique cetera donc si on se
positionne concurrentiel je pense que
oui on est concurrentiel pourquoi nous
concurrentiel parce que on peut faire
avec la technologie avec l'innovation on
peut faire des procédés qui coûtent pas
cher la fabrication par exemple
aujourd'hui un exemple le gravité de
nouveau moins d un fils qui vont faire
la purification vcli crise ne passe
qu'un exemple on a vu et des mamans qui
avaient des annonces de biens c'est pour
faire les 14
50% de la fabrication de la cathode
synergies donc le fait que notre énergie
elle est propre elle coûte pas cher en
ni concurrence y est et on fait pas
voyagé aussi un nos matériaux et aussi
le cosma les taxes aussi vers les
matériaux qui vient d'ailleurs donc nous
on a le libre échange et surtout on est
entre l'ontario et le québec on est dans
un pays donc il n'y a pas cet axe par
exemple qui ont fait rentrer les
matériaux d'ailleurs de chez nous de la
corée ou du japon là aujourd'hui on
parle d'une première
usine de fabrication de batteries pour
véhicules électriques
mais au québec qui a une en une
entreprise qui fabrique des batteries
lithium ion à boucherville où c'est oui
boucherville diffon n'oubliez pas la
batterie lithium-ion c'est la batterie
tout solide au lithium mais c'est la
première aujourd'hui c'est la seule
compagnie au monde qu'elle fabrique les
batteries au lithium tous solides sont à
boucherville en particulier leurs
applications les autobus de mercedes les
véhicules etc donc des fois on oublie
mais on est des pionniers au niveau de
la fabrication des batteries des
cellules mais mais la production elle
n'est pas énorme mais quand même on est
positionné aussi au québec aussi
pourquoi le prix baissent pourquoi le
coût des batteries baisse autant on l'a
vu dans notre graphique sa baisse de
plus en plus comment vous la regardez en
1990 ans sony c'est la première
compagnie qui a introduit la batterie
lithium-ion analyse à 80 90 ans 91 moi
j'étais au japon à l'époque donc le prix
était à peu près 3000 $ le kilowattheure
et c'était juste pour le marché des
portables de l'électronique et depuis
que tesla donc en 2010 le prix il devenu
un 1200 pourquoi parce que donc on
produit beaucoup de batteries donc on a
un produit beaucoup de matériaux donc le
fait qu'on produit beaucoup de volume le
prix baisse et aussi l'accélération vers
la pénétration des voitures électriques
il faudrait vraiment aller vers
électrifier la société on a besoin de
ces batteries pour réduire le prix tout
à l'heure j'ai vu votre chiffre qui sont
excellents en 2024 en parle de 100 $ le
kilowattheure à 100 dollars le kilo watt
heure la voiture électrique elle va être
égal à la voiture à essence et c'est
pour ça qu'on baisse les rabais je
rencontre électrique au québec moi je
suis d'accord avec ça parce que moi
pourquoi parce que
le prix de la batterie baisse la voiture
elle va être le même prix qu'une voiture
essence pourquoi on subventionne pas des
voitures à essence donc il faudrait que
six émotions ils vont cesser mois selon
moi aparté que le prix du kilowattheure
soit à 100 dollars est là parce que le
prix d'une voiture essence voitures
électriques elle va être en bas de 25
mille dollars lequel 25 mille dollars
donc autrement dit ça se devient très
concurrentiel un statut fiscal est de
moins en moins nécessaire pour
encourager les gens à acheter je suis je
suis d'accord il ça devient une voiture
une commodité la voiture électrique à
partir de 2025 et plus parfait en
souhaitant ne pas être sur des listes
d'attenté termine
à égaler aujourd'hui 40 gigawatts heure
là c'est l'équivalent à 80 kilowatts
heure on parle de 500 mille autres dont
vous pouvez voir la c6 on a plusieurs
gigas factory et ça on n'a pas le choix
il faut l'accélération on a vu un peu
les prix de l'essence qui sont à deux
dollars et lorsqu'on a des prix par
kilowattheure ici d'hydraulicité c'est
vraiment bénéfice pour pour l'éducation
du transport et les voitures électriques
monsieur zag et vous êtes très
intéressant merci d'avoir été avec nous
son prix pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit